you can't sustain doing something you  don't like especially if you're doing it  for money you will lose that game every  day of the week you might like Legos you  might like pancakes you might like  talking about meditation every person in  this room has something they like most  people don't do it around what they like  because they don't think there's money  in it I just wish people built more  financial infrastructure around the  things they actually like it works so  much more it's just too hard to build  like a career of meaning or a business  of meaning on something you don't like  if you're just doing it for the money  it's got no shot long term you could  make money plenty of people have but  like if you're going to really do it and  enjoy it back to happiness if it's  comedy like make a comedy skit go and  literally go to an open mic and try to  do stand up if you don't do you don't  know and you don't taste